Delegating a high-priority task to a person
who only delivers a bare-minimum style of
work ethic otherwise, will probably result
in the task not getting done.
The Foundation tried to snuff out SCP-682
with the help of SCP-2599, formerly known
as Zena Cho, a woman of Korean descent who’ll
carry out any order you give her...But only
around halfway.
That’s why the Foundation ordered her to
attack 682 until it was “200% dead”, so
even if she only did her task by halves, it’d
still be 100% dead.
By all accounts, she was actually doing a
pretty solid job, horrifically mutilating
the creature to a point of near-death, when
it suddenly yelled “KILL ME, YOU SACK OF
ORGANS, DO IT!”
And that order seemingly confused her, seeing
as only going halfway on killing the creature
was something she’d already done.
She remained motionless in the test chamber
until she was physically removed, and later
attempts to use her in 682’s termination
were fruitless.